يقف الرئيس الروسي دقيقه صمت على ارواح
متطوعين قتلوا في حرب اوكرانيا يشيد بوتين
بالاف من السجناء الجنائيين قاتلوا في
اوكرانيا نظير وعود باطلاق سراحهم يقول ان
هؤلاء سددوا دينهم للمجتمع يدشن بوتين
مرحله ما بعد يجين بريغوجين فلم يعد اسم
فاغنر يتردد في الكرملين ولا في اروقه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تستعيد موسكو عنه
بما تسميها كتائب المتطوعين وهم ممن
يتطوعون للقتال في اوكرانيا ولكن شرط ان
يدينوا بالولاء لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه يضع
بوتين امر عشرات الاف المتطوعين بين يدي
اندريه تروشي او ما يعرف بسيدو الاشيب وهو
احد القاده السابقين في فاجنر ويوصف بانه
كان حلقه الوصل بين فاجنر ووزاره الدفاع
الروسيه سيقود تروش جزء من
350 الف مقاتل تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
منذ بدايه العام في الحادي من سبتمبر من
العام الماضي اعلن الرئيس الروسي تعبئه
عسكريه جزئيه للدفاع عن الاراضي الروسيه
كانت هذه التعبئه العسكريه الاولى في
روسيا منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفقا
لهذا المرسوم استدعي نحو 300 ال من جنود
الاحتياط وهم جزء من نحو 25 20 مليونا هم
اجمالي قوه الاحتياط لدى روسيا وهم جميع
المواطنين الذين ادوا الخدمه العسكريه
الاجباريه وقد امر بوتين انذاك بان تشمل
التعبئه السجناء ممن ادينوا بارتكاب جرائم
خطيره فمنذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا جندت
مجموعه فاجنر ومثلها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
عشرات الاف المعتقلين في السجون الروسيه
مقابل وعود بالافراج عنهم لكن زج بهم في
جبهات القتال في اوكرانيا بعد نحو عام على
قرار بوتين على التعبئه يكشف الكرملين عن
قوه عسكريه ثانيه قوامها نحو 350 الف شخص
وقعوا جميعا عقودا مع وزاره الدفاع منذ
بدايه العام الحالي للقتال في اوكرانيا
الحد الادنى للاجر الشهري الذي يعرض على
الجنود المتعاقدين نحو 2700 دولار وهو ما
يقرب من ثلاثه اضعاف متوسط الاجور في
روسيا الى جانب بذلك استدعت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اخيرا 130 ال شخص ممن يستوفون
متطلبات قانون الخدمه العسكريه فيما يعرف
بتجنيد
الخريف تحشد روسيا وتعيد ترتيب صفوف
قواتها ما يشي بجوله جديده من القتال في
اوكرانيا اكثر شراسه فمقابل التحشيد
الروسي تتوالى شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه على
كيف تدخل دبابات ابرامز الامر الى ساحه
المعارك لتضاف الى نظيرتها الالمانيه
ليبرد وهي بعض من 31 دبابه وعدت الولايات
المتحده في يناير الماضي بتسليمها للجيش
الاوكراني ومن المتوقع ان تتسلم كيف ايضا
خلال ايام صواريخ اكمس ارض ارض وهي صواريخ
بالستيه بعيده المدى موجهه وشديده الدقه
يصل مداها الى نحو 300 كيلومتر